and when the trade was reported
slash announced it's not final obviously
until march 17 at 4 1 pm eastern
but when the news of the trade first
emerged that would send carson wentz to
the colts there
were follow-up reports suggesting that
the eagles were looking to bring in
someone else to compete with jalen hurts
and we know how the eagles feel about
the backup quarterback position it's the
top 15 spot on the roster yada yada yada
they need somebody else they need
somebody else
and who knows maybe they get some maybe
they take somebody with a sixth overall
pick in the draft
and that person becomes the starter
according to chris mortensen of espn
the owner of the team the only vote that
really counts right jeffrey lurie
wants support for jail and hurts okay
not competition right which would
seemingly take them out of play for a
quarterback at number
six uh first of all and and i because i
have some thoughts on that but first of
all
do you think jalen hurts should have a
backup who knows
i'm here i'm number two and i'm not the
starter i'm i'm here to support the
starter
or should there be a backup who is
capable of competing with and
potentially taking the starting job away
from jalen hurt well i think you you can
have a little bit of both there
to where you can get a backup in to go
hey listen
we're gonna give jalen every right to be
that guy
but we got you here in case it just
doesn't go well and falls apart
you know or he gets injured running the
football and doing those things
we got here you here because we think
you could every bit is compete with
jaylen and do that
but i mean they got to be careful about
you know
open competition and doing i mean
they're going to get themselves in the
same boat of like dividing the city
dividing the locker room
oh that guy had one bad game bench him
screw him get him out of there put the
other guy in
they got to be careful that's why i
would say like if they drafted a
quarterback in number six i would go
then you have to trade jalen hurts that
why so now you're gonna draft a
quarterback in number six he's gonna
play
bad in week three and everyone's gonna
boom and tell everybody to put jalen
hurts back in the game
you'll be in the same damn situation you
were in with carson wentz so
i i i i it's good to hear lori say that
and go ahead and see what jalen heard
scots and try to support it and go from
there
and and maybe you bring in a
mitchell trubisky or somebody like that
to be the
backup who can run and do those type of
things
and maybe he can be your fallback guy as
you go forward i don't know
what about nick falls what about foals
is the number two the ultimate backup
the guy who
if jalen hurts gets injured we'll come
in and get it done for you
i i listen i i hear you i mean that's
where
again too the head coaching hire and the
quarterback right now don't make sense
siriani came from the chargers with
frank reich and philip rivers and then
went to the colts
they're all about creative drop back
passing game and doing those things
that is you know the negative with jalen
hurts right now
so they're going to have to kind of get
out of their comfort zone as a coaching
staff i think and play a different way
too with jalen hurts
yeah nick foles makes sense certainly
you know but
again that they'll have he's he's a
legend in philadelphia
as soon as jalen hurts does something
bad or doesn't play well we know where
that's gonna go too but
it's it's of course not a horrible
option he is a great backup you know
he's not going to make a lot of noise or
waves
and i understand that but i'm i'm
interested to see where they go
with this and it's it's interesting to
hear jeffrey lurie say they're going to
go all in with jalen hurts right now
well and and let's let's be clear on
what was said
and what wasn't said and what's reported
and what's fact
and what may be part of a long con by
the philadelphia eagles this is where
i'm a little skeptical yeah i hear you
of this report because what better way
to make teams think that you're not
going quarterback at
six than to tell the world you don't
want competition for jaylen hertz
because the cat was kind of out of the
bag and there was a lot of speculation
oh they're gonna go quarterback at six
they're gonna go quarterback at six well
if you're one of the teams that's
drafting behind six
and mac jones is there at five and the
bengals are not gonna be drafting a
quarterback at five
right that's your spot you try to trade
up to five
to get mac jones before the eagles could
take him or whoever whoever's there
right the eagles need to make it clear
they don't want a quarterback at six if
they want to preserve their ability to
get a quarterback at six that's all part
of the pre-draft
shenanigans which are justified because
of the way the draft works
you need to create a ruse to make people
think that you're moving in a different
direction than you
are so jeff laurie not on the record
saying it jeff laurie leaking to a
reporter who
says it that that
creates a narrative so the eagles may
hope that oh no quarterback for them at
number six no they're not going
quarterback
they're all in with jalen hurts so it
wouldn't be the first time
something like that's happened and the
eagles know how to work the media and
the eagles know how to work a long con
so i'm not ruling out the possibility
that this is a long con by the eagles
aimed at getting
no one to trade up with the bengals to
take a quarterback at five and let that
quarterback fall through to number six
well yeah maybe yeah i mean
you're right this is the time of the
year where those narratives start to get
thrown out there and it's it's all about
positioning for the draft and propaganda
and those type of things
you know and the eagles are sitting
pretty i mean the way i look at it right
now is you just go okay trevor lawrence
won
jacksonville jaguars zach wilson two new
york jets
miami dolphins three i don't think
they're gonna draft the quarterback i do
think they're really looking if
deshawn watson finally does become or
nick casario starts answering answering
calls
i do think miami is going to go all in
on trying to get to sean watson i do i
got that sense
just from people i trust around the
league and things like that so
i don't think look at them as drafting a
quarterback you know at number four
uh who did we have there number four um
can you throw up oh like i lost number
four
falcons at number four with matt ryan i
don't think they're gonna go quarterback
right now at least i wouldn't matt
ryan's still got good years left i don't
think there's any reason to abandon that
ship right now and
you know for what he's making money-wise
it's not
a huge crush to their football team and
everything like that to have a top end
quarterback in football
so they are sitting there and you
mentioned the bangos they're not
drafting the quarterback at five they
are sitting in a spot where
yeah maybe they could get that third guy
if it falls in their lap the mac jones
or whoever they might
see fit as the third guy that'll be
interesting to see
uh but but i don't know man i just i
i i i just get the sense that they're
gonna let jalen hurts
kind of ride this out and they're gonna
see if they got something here
that's just where i feel about it that's
what my gut tells me right now
i just think that nothing reported or
said this time of year is binding on
anyone because it all has to be factored
into the broader smoke screens that
happen
you can't wear your true intentions
on your sleeve because then it will be
used against you if they come out and
say
hey we're looking for another
quarterback and they don't acquire one
in free agency or via trade
then it's the draft then they're in play
at six then a team like the panthers
that clearly is looking
to upgrade if they don't have any other
alternatives they know they need to get
in front of the eagles it's that simple
sometimes
and that could be the explanation here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports